walking is just like swimming but
without fins or a tail
and also there's no water how many times
did you catch moments in lucca that were
eerily similar
to disney's the little mermaid step
aside ariel
there's a new sea to land resident in
town and his name is luca
ariel and luca go on similar journeys as
do their parents
from very familiar images to the same
lines
we're covering 20 times luca copied the
little
on mermaid considering both the little
mermaid and luca take place under the
sea
it makes sense that schools of fish end
up being prominently featured in both
in the 1989 film the fish are present
for songs and swimming through the sea
in luca the schools of fish swim through
the sea often following lucca
when he isn't busy exploring life above
the sea that is
come on underwater treasure collecting
is all the rage in underwater disney
world
luca's fascination with the discovery of
human artifacts and his collecting of
them mimics just what disney princess
ariel did
what's more alberto's hideaway with all
the human stuff he's collected over time
reminds us very much of ariel's
underwater treasure trove
ariel what are you like how could you
what is all this ariel and luca have
shared some similar views
we are talking about the fascination
with looking up and watching the bottom
of the boats in the ocean
while both are very nervous knowing they
do need to be careful when it comes to
humans
neither can help but just look where do
boats come from
the stories of human monsters on land
above are the primary reason that king
triton and luca's parents give such
intense warnings to their children
the people on land are a threat so it's
a fair point in both cases
the curious fish gets caught both luca
and
ariel are curious about life above and
who can blame them
they're both fascinated with it and
really want to move from sea to land
ariel took action to follow prince eric
while lucas main motivation was the idea
of
riding a vespa once they're there both
end up being pretty big fans
the adventures both of them end up going
on are pretty magical
you know he's getting married getting
legs for the first time is bound to be
confusing
for ariel it only takes a couple of
tries and then
somehow she's waltzing with a prince
luca doesn't have the best teacher in
alberto
so it takes a bit of time and some
confusing instructions to get to the
point that he's actually able to run
both characters have to go through
learning how to do this pretty basic
action well enough to pass off as real
humans
and they become experts very quickly
you're in luck i basically invented it
in lucca alberto appeared to be the
expert of all things human
he says he knows how to use all the
objects what they're called
and makes some pretty misinformed claims
about the way the world works
really yeah and the big fish protects
them sound familiar
scuttle from the little mermaid claims
to be the expert as well with his
dinglehoppers and thingamabobs
what what is it it's a tingle hopper
dreaming of life on land can take a long
time
so long that both our leads were caught
missing from their posts
remember when ariel is missing for her
musical debut concert
the same thing happened to luca when his
mom caught him missing from his
shepherding post
luca did at least think ahead and place
this stone statue that
sort of resembles him in his place while
he was off adventuring with alberto
okay everyone this is uh
smooka ariel and luca are passionate and
rebellious souls
they just want to go where their hearts
take them it makes sense that both of
them have strict parents
both king triton and daniela make really
strong points to their children about
not going anywhere near the surface
and i am never never to hear of you
going to the surface again
no matter what but in the end of course
both luca and ariel disobey their
parents orders anyway
we do not talk think discuss contemplate
or go
anywhere near the surface among the
humans the rumors of monsters below
are plentiful in the little mermaid the
boat crews speak directly of king triton
and the wild amount of power he has
thought every good sailor knew about him
in lucca
there are rumors of sightings and even
rewards put out for finding the sea
monsters
as if there's something to be afraid of
the pressure to find and hunt down the
sea monsters is far
more intense to divide between the
humans and sea people than in the little
mermaid
we can almost hear the song le poisson
from the little mermaid as we see the
very familiar actions performed by
massimo chopping off the fish heads in
the kitchen
we've seen this before in prince eric's
kitchen where the chef was making a
seafood feast for the prince and
ariel
sebastian luca and alberto all go
through
quite a fight when they see how the
people on land feel about their fellow
kind
luca's first scares in the town square
when he sees the images and
of course statues of sea monsters being
attacked by humans
he and alberto both get a big shock when
this board with photos of fish
all over it appears remember poor
sebastian's encounter with the very
similar board of photos
while alberto and luca aren't as
vulnerable as sebastian at that moment
all of them look equally terrified
ariel doesn't really know how to use a
fork since she's gotten most of her how
to be human lessons from the
not-so-well-informed scuttle
however she does think she knows how to
use it and unfortunately
shows off her believed to be skills to
prince eric during their dinner
when served a plate of pasta with a fork
luke and alberto have no idea what it
could be for but
soon enough they end up learning how to
use forks really well
they definitely had better luck than
ariel the first time around
hey at the beginning of the little
mermaid we see a giant boat with
fishermen
catching fish aplenty except of course
for the one that escaped
fishing played a key role in luca as
well since of course
it was their first job helping julius
dad on the boat
that's where they also happen to prove
they'd be extra helpful with their
insider knowledge of life underwater
your friends don't know fish in the
little mermaid we have workers at the
palace hanging the laundry and gabbing
away about the new woman the princes met
we do get another laundry line on a
string in luca
except instead of putting clothes on it
luca's mom daniella is taking them down
to use the clothing for herself and
lorenzo
i'll just get this washed for you
we do sympathize with the parents of
these wild spirited souls
both have to go through the worry of
their children being missing
king triton has a crew of underwater
dwellers to help him out in the search
for his daughter
while daniella and lorenzo take matters
into their own hands
and make the journey to land themselves
so they can find their son and bring him
home
or so they think that's what the plan is
wow
it's fast scuttle the seagull is the
first one we see using the telescope in
the little mermaid
of course his knowledge is limited and
the instrument doesn't help him out so
much
we see a fascination with the telescope
come up again in luca
when julia uses it to show the details
of what the sky
really looks like and not to mention
proving to him that stars
aren't fish mermaid
both king triton and luca's mom daniella
have almost the exact same line
was i too hard on him wondering about
whether or not they were too hard on
their children
while they were strict it's all just
because they both care
so much for the well-being of their kids
do you uh think i was too hard on her
ariel luca and alberto
all go through their identities being
dramatically revealed
and it's not a fun experience for any of
them initially
ariel is discovered on the boat when she
misses getting her kiss before the
sunset
talk about bad timing alberto reveals
himself to julia
and then is caught by arcole who is
quick to attack
finally near the end of the puerto roso
cup race we have luca revealing himself
in front of the whole town
after alberto has come back to help him
they are
the winners in the end of course both
luca
and ariel get their happy endings with
the blessing and help of their parents
their dreams to live their lives on land
come true then i guess there's just one
problem left
luca and the little mermaid almost had
one other thing in common
alberto's character almost transformed
into a giant kraken
which we think might have looked a bit
like ursula's
transformation from human to evil
murwich what was your favorite
similarity between the two sealand
movies